el gobierno italiano anunció Este martes
un paquete de dos mil millones de euros
de ayudas para las familias y las
actividades golpeadas por las
inundaciones históricas que sacudieron
la región de Emilia romaña la semana
pasada el objetivo es mantener vivo El
tejido social y económico de esta región
considerada uno de los motores
económicos del país trescientos millones
de euros serán destinados a las empresas
afectadas 580 millones a los empleados
que han perdido su trabajo 300 millones
de euros a los trabajadores autónomos
para las familias el gobierno prevé
suspender temporalmente la obligación de
pago de impuestos y de préstamos
bancarios ligados al lugar de residencia
para las actividades agrícolas se prevén
indemnizaciones por 100 millones de
euros zonas enteras de la región siguen
todavía bajo el agua en las principales
ciudades afectadas continúa el trabajo
para liberar las calles de las montañas
de barro que han dejado las lluvias
torrenciales de las últimas dos semanas
en el norte de Italia y reparar las
infraestructuras destruidas los
habitantes inician a tomar conciencia
que el regreso a un semblante de
normalidad Será algo largo y muy muy
complicado